I think no one more than me
wants to get back to in-person meetings,
because for me
this is a relationship business
and that's why I love what I do.
That's why I love
getting up every morning
and coming to work,
because I love having these
meaningful conversation.
Jennifer Gross,
thank you so much for being on my show,
20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
Wonderful, Michael.
Thank you.
I'm so happy to be here today.
I'm very excited to hear
about fundraising,
about American Friends
of Tel Aviv University,
the great work that you're doing there,
and really getting into the mindset
of what it means to be that helpful
for both a research institution.
But I believe it's Israel's largest
university by in terms of more than
30,000 students?
That's correct.
We are Israel's largest university
and covering basically
every discipline you can think of.
Okay. So, I'm excited to learn more about
Tel Aviv University in itself,
but I'd love to start out
with a little bit about you.
Coming all the way
from investment banking.
I understand
that you have quite a bit
of experience with fundraising
over the years.
So, obviously you're the perfect person
for this job.
Tell me a little bit about yourself
all the way from North-Eastern,
how do you make your way
towards the financial world
to get to be the CEO
of this great organization
and this non-profit?
So, you're right, I started
actually at Northwestern in Chicago.
I started there
and graduated,
went to work for Morgan Stanley
as an investment banking analyst
and did that program for two years.
Concluding that program,
I move to institutional
money management marketing,
the [--] product of a company
that was a wholly owned sub
of Credit Suisse.
And from there,
it was home with my two children,
now 23 and 25 year olds for 10 years.
During that time,
I got very involved in nonprofit,
and I guess, as a proxy
for working professionally
and needing to have my own time,
I got very involved volunteering.
So, I took on all kinds
of volunteer roles.
But the common theme
throughout those roles
was really it was about raising money.
And my feeling was kind of
where the rubber hits the road,
in order to help the people,
it's about the money.
So, I get sort of cut my teeth
in fundraising as a volunteer
from many different organizations
are synagogue,
my children's school,
some Israeli organizations federation
in New York City.
And spent about 10 years doing that.
And as my children get older,
they were in Jewish Day school,
so their day was pretty long.
And it became clear to me that
they didn't really need me at home
anymore.
And sort of at the end of my time
being home with them,
they between after school
activities and playdates with friends,
they were sort of busy
until 7:00 at night.
So, I saw that
this is really my opportunity
to be able to go back to work.
Before you continue,
I need to understand a little bit
about the context of fundraising.
What does it mean to raise funds?
Because I'm coming
from the startup world,
from the venture capital world, where
it's very obvious what fundraising is.
It's a more
of a transactional type of deal.
It's a partnership that we're
going to also expect a return.
But the type of fundraising
that you're dealing with
doesn't necessarily expect
a monetary return.
So, talk to me about the,
what is the process of raising funds
as a nonprofit?
So for me, fundraising is
is really a relationship building.
It's all about relationship building.
It's Michael, you're a philanthropist
and you're looking to achieve
certain goals philanthropically.
And how are we,
Tel Aviv University,
best in class partners for you
to achieve that.
Right.
So, it's really having a conversation
and getting to know the potential donor
and what moves him or her
and what they care about.
And again, how we can help them
realize or hopefully even exceed
what they're trying to do.
So the return,
well, you're right, it's not,
I sort of got my start in fundraising,
raising money for hedge funds
from institutions.
And you're absolutely right
with transactional.
And they were looking
to generate a certain return
to be able to meet their needs.
And this is very different.
This is really about speaking to people
who are philanthropically inclined
and who want to,
who have certain measures
that they want to achieve and really
either helping them zone in
on exactly what that is or how to do it.
Okay. So, it sounds to me that there are
a few different verticals here.
One of them is the people
that are already
considering themselves philanthropic.
They're known as philanthropists.
And then you're finding
some sort of alignment
between your mission,
their mission,
and then it's a win-win situation.
But I'm sure there are also people
that are not yet considered
philanthropists, but they may have
the means to contribute.
They may have missions that are aligned
and you're also tasked
with trying to find those people
and explain to them
what philanthropy could be.
Right?
You're absolutely right.
So, that oftentimes
is a longer lead time,
because that's not just talking to you,
someone who cares about certain
to achieve certain things
philanthropically,
but that's talking to you about really
sort of that's a much larger
conversation about values,
what you value,
what's important to you,
what sort of legacy
or what sort of impact
you're looking to have.
For people who aren't yet philanthropic,
but to your point,
have the ability to be philanthropic,
it's really a conversation of sort of
why is this the right thing to do,
why is this the appropriate thing for you
to do at this stage of your life,
why you why not somebody else.
And how can you feel so good about what
you're doing and what you're making
possible and the impact
that you're having on others,
which can seem sort of counterintuitive
to iron the money.
It's my money.
So, sometimes there's a little bit
of a golf that you have to transcend
in terms of why being philanthropic
is appropriate
and not even just appropriate,
but is really extraordinarily uplifting.
So, why does a person
become philanthropic?
You're saying
it's extremely rewarding, uplifting,
but I don't think it's that obvious
to the average person.
Why spending money
or donating money is automatically,
you know, a rewarding,
enriching experience?
So, why does one become philanthropic?
And what does one gain out of it?
Because it is a two sided street.
One becomes philanthropic,
I guess, for one of two reasons.
One is, they really feel like
I've been given certain
assets and certain resources
and giving back is either something
that I want to do or I feel
is my responsibility to do,
or is the right thing to do.
So sort of internally motivated,
the external motivation
is sometimes about really introducing
this person or people to the needs
and to sort of the broader landscape
out there.
And I think pointing out the needs,
the opportunities and the impact
that that's possible.
Because in my experience,
I've seen that when you see, look,
private philanthropy is dwarfed
by governmental spending.
But governmental spending,
there are tremendous holes
and there are governments,
Institutions tend to like to fund
specific projects,
but without having the lights on
and the staff paid
and the copy machine serviced,
you cannot run those programs.
So, I think when people can see,
assuming someone either is
or is willing to become
philanthropically minded,
when people can see
what private philanthropy
can make possible,
it becomes sort of addicting.
And you realize the impact
when you really get to meet the grantees
or to see the programs
and to see what it is
that you can make possible,
everybody loves spending on themselves
and their families and trips and home
or whatever it is,
but this is totally different.
And for those who have, I think
there's a real argument to be made about,
or I should say,
the way that we've raised our children
is sort of the measure to which you have
is the measure to which
you have a responsibility to give back.
I love that.
I have to say, growing up in both
in Palo Alto, Tel Aviv,
I'm right now a student at Stanford while
also a senior associate of J-Ventures,
and at the start of Hippo,
I'm surrounded by people
that are very, very motivated
and ambitious.
And a lot of these people are excited
to go into the startup scene,
potentially to be
going towards an exit strategy
or running a public company,
a very successful one,
or alternatively going into
investment banking
or other venture capital
types of funds,
all of which have high potential
for making a lot of money.
And when I asked them
what would the motivation
behind the money, very rarely do I hear,
I want to be a philanthropist
when I'm older, right?
I want to be a philanthropist.
Jen, I'm seeing the work
that a lot of the brilliant people,
like the top tech leaders,
that they're spending large,
sometimes large chunks of their money
on having a positive impact
on the world.
And I can't help but get excited about
potentially, if I do get a chance
to have means for myself
to be able to contribute as well,
it sounds like a fantastic impact.
But Jennifer, tell me a little bit about
Tel Aviv university,
what you're doing there
from the United States.
I believe you are one of the
biggest donors,
or the groups that are channeling funds
towards Tel Aviv University, right?
We are the largest donor
to the university.
Our support we raised
I would say around
$35,000,000 a year,
which we send to Israel, to university.
We're number one.
And I'm proud to say that
in addition to us being number one,
Israel is number two.
So, the Israeli philanthropic community,
while it's younger
and more, sort of in its infancy,
has really and you've started to see
Israelis with real means start to give.
So, we're proud that that we're first
and that Israel's second.
I think that's something
really significant.
Israelis are seeing the potential
and are investing in their university
in the same way that
Americans are investing
in their universities.
So, I think that's something
that's critical.
It's something that I haven't had
since I was at Northwestern.
And to get to the deans
and the professors and the researchers
and working in the labs
and doing the kind of cutting edge
work and innovation,
it's just so generative
and it's something that's so exciting.
And I think it empowers all of us
at the American Friends
to be able to tell the story
and to really try to convey
what's going on,
and the excitement
and the possibilities,
not just for changing
what's going on in Israel on the ground,
but really
the ripple effect of the technology
and the innovation and the discoveries
at the university
are really rippling out worldwide.
And that's something that's,
that's extraordinary.
And when you speak to somebody
about giving money
and about being philanthropic,
especially when you speak to someone
in any aspect
of the financial services industry,
whether that's hedge funds
or whether that's the startups or venture
or angel or private equity,
sort of anywhere in financial services,
I think everyone's looking for impact.
And what are the exciting things
about investing in Israel?
And not to say
this is at the expense of anyone
investing in their
universities in the US,
but that's sort of the purchasing power
of a dollar in Israel
versus in the US is just exponential.
So, we, Tel Aviv University was fortunate
that we're doing collaboration's
through the correct foundation
with Stanford.
And so, it's not one to one,
one researcher from Stanford,
one from Tel Aviv, it's one to six.
So, if you're philanthropic
and if you're thinking about the impact
and what your funds can do
and how they can go further,
that's definitely something that we see.
We have somebody who has been giving
multiple millions of dollars
for cancer research in the US.
And he just gave to Tel Aviv University
because the ability to have an impact
and for those research dollars
to go even further exists in Israel
in a way that it doesn't exist here.
I think, that's just remarkable.
But going to the beginning,
why does the university
need to raise funds?
Why does a university
need millions of dollars
in order to operate?
It's a great question
because you ask yourself,
you're the biggest university in Israel,
you're public university,
why isn't that the government's
responsibility?
It's a great question.
And I would tell you that it is
the government's responsibility.
And the amount of money
that the government gives the US,
the amount of money that the government
gives the university is it far exceeds
any other sources of funds.
And that those funds,
that funding level
gets universities to good.
Tel Aviv university
would be a good university.
You would have access to good researchers
and good equipment, but not great.
The difference from good to great,
the way that we're able to reverse
the brain drain
and to bring all the postdocs
who go out of Israel
because they have to do the postdoc work
that's going to be really respected
in academia to be able to bring them back
and to be able to give them
enough lab equipment
and access to postdocs,
all of that,
that's really private philanthropy.
That's where private philanthropy
comes in.
So, in order for the university
to do all it can do for Israel
and for the world,
it's dependent on
private philanthropy.
Wow.
So, it makes perfect sense.
The donations are
what bring good to great.
And obviously,
when I'm even trying to start comparing
the endowment or the funds that,
in places like Stanford or Harvard
or MIT have compared to the numbers
that you said before, you know,
it's literally adding zeros at the end.
Which is pretty remarkable
considering that Tel Aviv University
and other universities in Israel
do such cutting edge technology.
And we have some of the
brightest people in the world.
So, it's just phenomenal.
What is your day to day look like,
you and your team,
as you're working towards helping
Tel Aviv from the United States?
Are we talking about pre-pandemic
or post-pandemic?
Oh, last year or both.
So, pre-pandemic when I started,
I set a goal for myself,
which was in the first year to get out
and meet all the members of our board.
And the members,
the university has a board of governors,
to meet the members
the members of the Board of Governors
from the US,
and to meet our major donors.
So, I would say my day to day until March
was basically on a plane,
probably more often than not
getting to San Francisco, to LA,
to Chicago, to Miami, all over to Israel,
to really meet people
and really understand sort of their
relationship to the university
and opportunities
and just really fill them in also
with what we were doing.
And that was a real focus.
Well, then, sort of covid hit
and everything had to pivot.
And see that we took the opportunity,
when I joined in my role,
there had been sort of a gap.
For 10 months there was no CEO.
They have a CEO search on.
And so, when I started,
it became clear that
we really needed
some internal planning and structure
in order to be
as strong of an institution
as we could be.
So, when the pandemic hit,
we took advantage of the opportunity
or the lack of opportunity to travel
and to have face to face meetings
and really looked internally and started
a strategic planning process
where we came up with an overall
organizational strategic plan,
a fundraising plan,
a communications plan
where we really designed,
with regards to the fundraising team,
we designed what are their pipelines
going to look like
and how are we going to structure
their sort of workflow.
We really took on
looking at all of our communications
and all of our materials
and how do we want to change that.
So, we did this sort of
internal processes and planning
that have served us well.
And I think when things do open up,
we really will be able
to come out strong.
Wow, that's just amazing.
And so, what does the future hold
for American Friends
of Tel Aviv University or for fundraising
for universities in general?
Which is the future hold,
the future holds,
I think no one more than me
wants to get back to in-person meetings
because for me,
this is a relationship business.
And that's why I love what I do.
That's why I love
getting up every morning
and coming to work, because I love
having these meaningful conversations.
And I'm fortunate that sort of
where I am in my career,
the conversations are really
with people who are, for the most part,
philanthropically inclined
and certainly have the means.
So, it's an exciting,
it's an interesting,
it's always a meaningful conversation.
So, I'm hopeful we get back to that.
I think in terms of
the near term,
it looks a lot like trying
to simulate or give people
a similar feeling to being
in someone's living room
and hearing from
a cutting edge researcher
or someone who's doing
cutting edge innovation,
trying to use the technology
that we have to make it more interactive.
And after the pandemic hit
and we all went into lockdown,
we began doing weekly webinars,
which then in the last couple months
became every other week.
But I think people have gotten
Zoom fatigue,
and people want to connect.
And so, I think ways
that we can connect people
in smaller groups
or more around more specific interests,
I think that's exciting.
100%.
I think that it's very exciting
and I'm very hopeful
that it goes back to reality
as soon as possible.
Jennifer, thank you
for taking time to do this.
Before we finish,
I need three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
It's very tough to put oneself down
to three words.
Very difficult.
I would say my three words
in alphabetical order
because I'm not sure
I would have to think longer
if I have to organize them otherwise
are caring, hard-working and positive.
It sounds like those are three things
that you definitely need as you're going
about the mission that you're doing.
And I think that it's inspiring
for me, looking at your background,
going all the way from investment banking
and those financial institutions
and making your way towards philanthropy
and really making an impact.
And I haven't really
even thought of that,
about a dollar invested in
in a place like Tel Aviv University
versus a dollar spent
in many other places.
It's a different impact.
It's not to say
that it's better or worse,
but it's a different impact.
And it sounds very, very exciting
and that you are making
a very positive impact.
So, thank you very much.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
Thank you. You too.